la presse locale invité dans sa
permanence pour l' annonce de sa
candidature la mère de plaisir joséphine
coleman ce berger se lance dans la
campagne pour les municipales
objectif briguer un troisième mandat
après avoir été élu maire en 2012 et sa
réélection en 2014
il ya un bilan important qui a été fait
par l'ensemble des équipes jury de
mandature complète et ce bilan mérite
aujourd'hui je pense véritablement
d'être continuer nous avons mis en place
deux grands projets qui sont des projets
structurants de la collectivité
cette dynamique il faut la continuer
mais en même temps on a entendu que ce
désir de bien-être de ville nature de
ville humaine de ville également
entreprenante et puis de ville aussi
responsable tous ces mots ce sont des
mots former des mots que l'on retrouve
aujourd'hui dans une vraie volonté notre
population ville nature humaine à
responsable et entreprenante les quatre
axes du projet de la candidate en cours
de finition sa liste déjà complète sera
renouvelée à 50 % par rapport à 2014
autour de moi j'ai une série de
personnes qui sont très divers et variés
des non inscrits et aussi des personnes
qui vont dans divers mouvements qui
aujourd'hui se sont rapprochés de nous
et nous avons une ouverture totale à
divers mouvements les plus jeunes en
vingt ans déjà
on a énormément de personnes entre 20 et
35 ans ont aussi rendu compte en en
regroupant toutes ces personnes qui
avaient des personnes qui étaient
représentatives de tous les quartiers de
la ville et dieu sait si plaisir est
grand
la liste et le programme seront
présentées au mois de janvier 2000 vain
pour le moment face à l patrick jeantet
rex membre de la majorité municipale
s'est lancée avec une liste intitulée
remettons plaisir en marche